[Aplausos]
[Música]
latinoamérica es probablemente la región
con menos ambición militar del mundo
[Música]
y sus gobiernos gastan relativamente
poco en defensa y en general salvo
alguna excepción eso de crear grandes
modernos y poderosos ejércitos no es una
prioridad
[Música]
a pesar de ello el tema de las fuerzas
armadas ha sido durante años en esta
región un tema controvertido muy
controvertido y no es para menos la
segunda mitad del siglo 20 no fue
precisamente un tiempo tranquilo para
latinoamérica durante todo este periodo
de tiempo y especialmente en los años 60
y 70 esta región fue uno de los
territorios de todo el mundo más
afectados por la fuerza militar tal cual
como lo escucháis los que nos estáis
viendo desde allí lo sabéis bien
e
[Música]
huertas armadas son conscientes de la
magnitud de la tarea a realizar
[Música]
ah
los fracasos
en estos años prácticamente todos los
países de la región participaron en lo
que se convirtió en una especie de
macabra tradición formada por golpes de
estado juntas militares y por supuesto
mucha represión echemos un vistazo por
ejemplo a 1978
[Música]
[Aplausos]
por esta costa
no abundan estas playas
para dar nacimiento al pero actual un
parón y más orgulloso se sentaría la
doctora
en ese año entre otros países atentos
argentina bolivia brasil chile ecuador
paraguay perú cuba nicaragua honduras el
salvador panamá e incluso el pacífico
uruguay estaban bajo dictaduras
militares y perdonadme si me he dejado
alguno como veis la lista fue larga
demasiado larga y si españa también
sufrió durante 40 años una dictadura
militar
aquí elecciones históricas ninguna
[Música]
i
españa cumple
en los momentos actuales su designio
providencial
[Música]
el caso es que todo esto era algo tan
exagerado que hasta en los cómics de
tintín si en los cómics de tintín se
asociaba a latinoamérica con dictaduras
militares dictaduras de todos los
colores de izquierdas de derechas pero
eeuu anti eeuu más duras más blandas
pero todas con un elemento común la
represión y si en el marco de la guerra
fría y la lucha de bloques muchas de
estas dictaduras fueron apoyadas desde
washington en el marco de lo que se
conoció como en la 'operación cóndor'
se conoce como 'operación cóndor' un
siniestro plan de inteligencia y
colaboración entre las dictaduras
militares de la argentina de videla el
chile de pinochet el paraguay del
general stroessner el brasil de joao
figueiredo y el uruguay de bordaberry
todo con el apoyo de la cia para lograr
un objetivo perseguir y aniquilar a la
oposición política especialmente a los
grupos de izquierdas apoyados por el
régimen soviético
claro que no penséis que las dictaduras
del otro color político fueron mejores
para nada el caso amigos es que con esta
historia no es difícil imaginarse porque
el tema de las fuerzas armadas ha sido
algo tan controvertido pero bien han
pasado más de 30 años desde este oscuro
periodo y en este vídeo queremos
responder a varias preguntas cuál es el
estado de los ejércitos actualmente en
latinoamérica qué funciones tienen
podríamos llegar a considerar una gran
unión militar
pues bien veámoslo
[Música]
ejércitos en latinoamérica
antes de empezar y como curiosidad
amigos os hago otra pregunta cuáles
pensáis que son los ejércitos más
fuertes más poderosos de latinoamérica
bueno esto siempre es bastante subjetivo
pero según el global fair power index
2017 un indicador que trata de medir con
diferentes parámetros como armamento o
capacidades logísticas que ejércitos son
más poderosos este es el top five
latinoamericano en primer lugar seguro
que no os sorprende brasil el gran
coloso regional le siguen por este orden
méxico argentina perú y colombia
ahora bien más allá de esta curiosidad
lo cierto es que latinoamérica es la
región del mundo que menos presupuesto
dedica a defensa en 2016 fue poco más
del 1% de su pib unos 67 mil millones de
dólares esto supone un nivel de gasto
mucho más bajo que la media del resto
del mundo pero es que además los
ejércitos latinoamericanos tienden a
tener un número de soldados bastante
altos
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea en total la
región tiene algo más de un millón
setecientos treinta mil soldados lo que
al final provoca que sean ejércitos poco
modernos y con bastantes problemas de
operatividad fijémonos en el ejército
más importante el brasileño brasil será
hasta cada año 23 mil 700 millones de
dólares en su ejército parece mucho
verdad el problema es que tiene más de
340 mil soldados con lo que las tres
cuartas partes del presupuesto van a
parar a salarios y pensiones si a esto
le añadimos los aprovisionamientos
básicos pues el dinero que queda para
equipo es muy muy reducido y en el resto
de latinoamérica las ratios son
similares de media el 70% del gasto se
va a parar directamente a salarios
en otras palabras los ejércitos
latinoamericanos por lo general tienen
muchos soldados y pocos equipos algo que
directamente está relacionado con su
naturaleza atentos
mirando hacia adentro
[Música]
como hemos visto amigo si hablamos de
ejércitos guerras y conflictos entre
países podemos decir que latinoamérica
es una de las regiones más pacíficas de
todo el mundo el último conflicto armado
se produjo ni más ni menos que en 1994
en lo que se conoció como la guerra del
cenepa que enfrentó a ecuador y perú
aunque ni siquiera hubo una declaración
de guerra formal
desde entonces se ha impuesto una
tendencia que ha convertido a
latinoamérica en todo un referente
mundial cada vez que hay un conflicto
entre países en vez de amenazar a la
otra parte con bombas y cañones en
latinoamérica se prefiere recurrir al
arbitraje internacional y a las cortes
internacionales de justicia es lo que
actualmente por ejemplo está ocurriendo
con el conflicto entre bolivia y chile
por la salida al mar un conflicto que se
está resolviendo en la corte
internacional de justicia de la haya
bolivia presenta réplica en la demanda
contra chile en la corte de la haya por
el acceso al mar sin embargo a nivel
interno las cosas cambian por completo
podríamos decir que latinoamérica tiene
el récord de ser al mismo tiempo la
región más pacífica y también la más
violenta no tranquilos no he perdido la
cabeza me explico
[Música]
entre países no hay ninguna amenaza
seria de guerra pero si hablamos de
violencia eso es otra cosa mirad en
latinoamérica vive el 8% de la población
mundial pero se concentra el 33 por
ciento de los homicidios de las 50
ciudades más violentas del mundo en 2016
42 se encuentran en latinoamérica arturo
sotomayor profesor en el departamento de
ciencia política y geografía de la
universidad de texas así que como parece
que los enemigos están en casa los
militares latinoamericanos se centran
sobre todo en labores dentro de casa
como por ejemplo enfrentarse a
guerrillas narcotraficantes o hacer
frente a la violencia en general de
hecho en la región cada vez es más común
que los militares sustituyan a los
policías en muchas tareas de seguridad y
vigilancia y es que aquí el problema
amigos es que la evidencia muestra que
eran los soldados esto de ejercer de
policías pues no se les da precisamente
bien no me creéis pues atentos
[Música]
la solución insuficiente frente a lo que
podríamos pensar a primera vista las
tasas de criminalidad en brasil o en
méxico lejos de reducirse han aumentado
desde que los soldados participan en
tareas de seguridad ciudadana de hecho
en las cinco ciudades más peligrosas del
mundo
caracas acapulco san pedro sula distrito
central y victoria hay presencia militar
y eso no es todo
[Música]
los casos de abuso de poder detenciones
extrajudiciales o víctimas colaterales
también se han incrementado con la
presencia militar lo que además favorece
y alimenta una cultura de la violencia
que desgraciadamente hoy está demasiado
extendida en toda la región
el problema es que los soldados son
fuerzas entrenadas básicamente para la
guerra y para eliminar al enemigo no
para imponer el orden y el estado de
derecho para conseguir esto lo que se
necesitan son detectives tribunales y
jueces policías de proximidad
colaboración ciudadana etcétera etcétera
podemos echar un vistazo a lo que ha
ocurrido por ejemplo en mexico
[Música]
nada más llegar al poder en diciembre de
2006 felipe calderón declaró la guerra
contra las drogas y puso al ejército a
pie de calle desde entonces no sólo no
se ha reducido el tráfico de narcóticos
sino que la tasa de homicidios se llegó
a triplicar el ejército simplemente no
es suficiente en casos muy graves puede
echar una mano pero no puede llevar la
dirección de los asuntos internos porque
simplemente no funciona si se que la
policía corrupta es un problema pero no
se arregla simplemente recurriendo al
ejército algo que por cierto tiene
además otros dos grandes problemas el
primero el riesgo político fijaos en
estas palabras las fuerzas armadas de
américa latina deben ser anti
imperialistas evo morales- qué queréis
que os diga a mí esto de ver a políticos
utilizando a los militares para defender
sus ideas políticas sean las que sean me
parece algo muy pero que muy peligroso
pensad que el uso del poder de la fuerza
siempre será tentador es lo que ha
ocurrido por ejemplo en venezuela donde
las fuerzas armadas se han convertido en
algo así como laguardia
vitoriana del régimen bolivariano de
nicolás maduro
[Música]
si eso de tener a las fuerzas armadas
mirando para adentro no suele deparar
cosas buenas y por si no fuese
suficiente también está el problema de
la corrupción veréis la industria
militar es una industria opaca y de
grandes contratos dos ingredientes
básicos de la corrupción atentos a lo
que ocurrió en 2010 en la república
dominicana en 2010 un gran escándalo de
corrupción afectó a las fuerzas armadas
dominicanas por la compra fraudulenta de
ocho aviones supertucanos a la empresa
brasileña embraer se sospecha que 87
millones de dólares se quedaron en manos
de miembros de la alta jerarquía
política y militar del país y eso es
sólo un ejemplo ni siquiera el más
importante pues bien teniendo todo esto
en cuenta no sería bueno pensar en una
gran alianza militar
[Música]
la otan latinoamericana me vais a
permitir que ponga sobre la mesa una
idea que tal vez os pueda parecer
totalmente descabellada visto lo visto
no sería bueno pensar en construir una
gran alianza militar una gran alianza en
la que los diferentes países se
organizaran y aportarán diferentes
unidades y cuerpos para diferentes
tareas
de esta forma a cada país podría
concentrar una buena parte de su
presupuesto militar en crear un ejército
bien equipado e integrado con el resto
de ejércitos de los demás países creas
en una fuerza operativa y con capacidad
de despliegue rápido
[Música]
y esto amigos creo de verdad tendría
muchas ventajas se reduciría la
influencia de los militares en la
política se garantizaría la soberanía de
todos los países y además en caso de ser
necesario por ejemplo ante catástrofes
naturales los países latinoamericanos
contarían con un ejército capaz de
desplegarse rápido y con altos niveles
de operatividad
además empujaría la necesaria
integración latinoamericana y el propio
papel de esta región en el mundo
[Música]
pero sobre todo amigos liberaría muchos
recursos tanto económicos como humanos
para impulsar tareas de seguridad
ciudadana capaces de reducir las
altísimas tasas de violencia
a tasas de violencia que hoy por hoy son
sin lugar a dudas uno de los grandes
frenos para el despegue definitivo de la
región ojo en cierto modo la unión
europea está tratando de hacer algo
similar así que puede que suene
descabellado pero no tanto al fin y al
cabo costa rica hace décadas que
suprimió su ejército y los resultados en
términos de seguridad han sido mejores
que los de sus vecinos se dice amigos lo
hemos visto aquí ya en visual político
que el siglo 21 va a ser el siglo de la
india de china y en general de asia
[Música]
y yo me pregunto por qué no puede ser el
siglo de latinoamérica bueno ahora turno
para ti estarías a favor de una gran
unión militar latinoamericana déjanos tu
respuesta en los comentarios y también
en esta encuesta
me parece amigos que esta vez el debate
va a estar muy caliente si te ha gustado
el vídeo echarnos una mano
compartiéndolo con tus amigos dándole a
like y por supuesto si aún no lo has
hecho
no olvides suscríbete a visual político
por cierto antes de irte una noticia el
próximo viernes 24 de noviembre y
también el sábado 25 vamos a estar el
'león' con nuestros amigos de student
por liberty hablaremos sobre
globalización y casos de éxito en la
descripción os dejamos más detalles
si podéis no dudéis en pasaros un saludo
y hasta la próxima
[Música]
fundamentos actuales su designio
providencial pagar nacimientos pero
actuales un parón
finalmente orgulloso varían la factura
[Música]